for more than two decades thriller
writer and TV host Brad Meltzer has
revealed some of history's biggest
secrets he told us about Ronald Reagan
carrying a gun while serving as
president and he helped us find the
missing 9/11 flag that firefighters
raised at Ground Zero his fictional
conspiracy theme stories have made him a
New York Times bestselling author he has
sold 12 million books in the US alone
that's a lot of books Brad Meltzer's new
book it's called the escape artist is
his 12th novel tells the story of an
Army sergeant who was presumed dead
after her plane mysteriously crashes in
Alaska after the government confirms her
death mortician at Dover Air Force Base
discovered she's still alive and she's
on the run Brad Meltzer joins us at the
table welcome back to you Brad always
good to see you so you grabbed me with
the first line number one this has got
to be a movie you got to figure this out
but these were the last 32 seconds of
her life and so instantly we're off to
the races is that how you started with
that that theory yeah no I I that was
that first chapter is the last chapter I
wrote I went back around and started
with this idea that NOLA Brown is in
this plane crash everyone says she's
dead but as her body's being laid to
rest by our hero Zig he finds a secret
note inside her body and the note says
NOLA you were right keep running and he
realized she's not dead she's alive
she's on the run she's the escape artist
and like we just ruined chapter one but
there's Chapter two really
why is she on the run but the thing that
was so fascinating is the Dover Air
Force Base the unprecedented access that
you got there you call it America's most
important funeral home it really is you
know a few years ago I was doing a USO
tour entertaining our troops in the
Middle East and it was after that I
found out about Dover and of course I
knew that Dover is where we lay to rest
are amazing soldiers who fall in battle
and what I didn't realize is that Dover
also gets the biggest cases so when the
space shuttle went down went to Dover
when 9/11 happened the Pentagon victims
went there but it also holds where our
biggest spies are across the globe and
no one's supposed to know where they are
they all go to Dover - which means Dover
is a place that's built on secrets and
mysteries so how could I not set a
thriller there and the mortician has a
kind of code
about taking care of and caring for the
bodies because of the relationship with
the families which works into this whole
question of whether the main character
is alive yeah and what's amazing is is I
was blown away by that is you'll see the
you know in a normal situation if
something happens near disfigure they
put you in a coffin and you get a closed
casket but not at Dover at Dover they
will work so hard because they'll take
14 hours to rebuild the cheekbones in
someone's face because the family wants
to see their child one last time or
they'll rebuild someone's hand because
they want to make sure that a mother
specifically asked and I hold my son's
hand one last time we are a country
starving for heroes right now this is
where the best of the best of us work on
the best of the best of us and I want to
really show them as heroes so many
unsung heroes you said that Noah Brown
is your favorite protagonist character
why you know what because NOLA is you
know I love the people have said oh
she's like The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo and you know I'll take that
compliment any day but Noah's not like
anyone else I wrote because Noah is that
character who grabbed me by the throat
and said pay attention to me she doesn't
need to be saved by anyone she's on her
own terms and she's had a rough life
he's had this rough life and you know
all of us have been through situations
where we whether it's addiction whether
it's abuse but where we have to claw our
way back we got to climb out of the
crater and Noah was that person who's
climbing out of the crater who's truly
trying to come back to life and to me I
looked at that in my own life as my
lesson but for Zig and for NOLA in this
book we all need to know how do we come
back to life the the thing that's so
fascinating about your books is I always
learn something you know in addition to
entertaining us you also educate us for
instance the gutbucket
no matter how big you are remember this
John all your organs can fit in one
bucket I thought that was interesting
someone is dead you boil water stick
their finger put their fingers in it you
can get their fingerprints the two oh
two four five six preface means the
White House is calling 202 406 means
Secret Service's calling and I google
all this stuff and it's true but the
thing that stuck out to me the most was
about if you swallow a note when you're
dying yeah let's talk about you learn to
you learned that at Dover what what is
that exactly yeah so when I when I
research a book I always go to the
experts and I say here's my plot and
tell me how to make it even better and I
said them could you
hide a secret message on your body that
someone could find later and they said
to me it's over that if you were on a
plane that was going down and you did it
early enough if you ate a note that the
liquids in your stomach could
potentially protect that paper and they
said to me this was the ultimate message
in a bottle and I said that's amazing
they said but it's happened already I
said what are you talking about they
said on 9/11 and they explained to me
that on 9/11 when they were going
through the victims bodies they actually
found a note a secret note inside
someone's stomach what I did say and
that's what I said I said what did it
say and of course they wouldn't tell me
I respect that privacy but one of the
things I thought it had to be someone in
the military because who has the
wherewithal to think of that but then I
realized you know what this note had to
have been is that thing we're all
looking for connection right we want to
love and we want to be loved then when
my parents died the one thing that I
remember taken away from that the one
calm I've found was I got to say goodbye
and I think in that note in that moment
is that hope right that's what it is is
that when you send that ultimate message
in a bottle that will be heard Wow that
story just gave me chills quickly you're
known for your thrillers as well as your
nonfiction work what do you prefer I
listen I love our I am books I am
Abraham Lincoln I am Rosa Parks I am
Harriet Tubman but a thriller is a house
that I get to build with my own hands
yeah and when it comes to the escape
artists that I get to take people into
the world of magicians and you know that
magicians actually worked for the
government that in 1898 we had a
magician in charge of the secret for my
favorite page one in the whole book
right in 1898 we had a magician in
charge of the Secret Service I was like
I need to use that we'll talk more in
the commercial break because I don't
know a lot of these things Brad Nessler
thank you well the scape artist goes on
sale tomorrow and you are watching CBS
this morning